[Musique]
et oui il peut apporter les solutions
grâce au satellite
évidemment qui nous permettent
d'observer la terre et d'agir pour
trouver justement des solutions à ce
réchauffement climatique nous avons
notamment les programmes copernicus qui
sont des satellites qui nous permettent
d'observer les océans l'augmentation de
la température des niveaux qui permet
également de suivre l'activité humaine
et dégagement de pollution à travers le
monde et donc nous pouvons à partir de
ces données réagir pour inverser la
courbe bien nous votons jeudi une
résolution sur le green deal donc la
lutte contre le réchauffement climatique
par leur part un organe bien j'ai écrit
un amendement qui va demander
l'utilisation du spatial pour observer
la terre est pire pour trouver ces
fameuses solution en ayant observé les
différents cataclysme donc pour moi il
est clair que il ne peut pas y heures un
green deal sérieux s'il n'y a pas un
investissement sérieux dans le domaine
spatial
[Musique]
c'est déjà le cas aujourd'hui puisque
l'australie a appelé au secours l'union
européenne et six satellites copernicus
qui fournissent en temps réel des images
de tous les incendies qui sont en
australie ce qui permet d'évacuer les
populations ce qui permet d'aiguiller
les pompiers dans leur lutte contre
contre le sinistre c'était déjà le cas
en amazonie c'était aussi le cas dans le
cadre de tempête qui peut y avoir en
amérique du nord
on peut dire encore une fois que
l'europe est leader dans ce domaine là
et que il faut insister pour que
copernicus puisse encore avoir davantage
de moyens pour lutter partout dans le
monde contre c'est cindy
[Musique]